it has been a good week of Netflix binge
as I can say that a sylvania season so
Castlevania Season 2 is the second
season of Netflix Castlevania or if you
just add the episodes of season 1 season
2 it really makes one season porn is
Trevor Belmont Sipho Alec are they're
all on their quest to take down Dracula
Dracula who is still hell-bent on wiping
out humanity and these are the
continuing Adventures of Dracula really
this is Drac - this season it's one of
the biggest changes between season 1 and
season 2 although Dracula was the point
and star of the first episode of the
first season of Castlevania which is a
great first episode rest of that season
did belong to Trevor Belmont so wasn't
season 1 ended I was like alright those
three are gonna be the star really not
the case season 2 largely concentrates
on Dracula what's going on inside the
castle dissension among the ranks some
of the vampires don't like how he's
handling things right here lose really
depressed he just stares through this
fireplace a lot of the time others a bad
thing cuz he's awesome in this season he
has these human spirit forges Hector and
Isaac who are from Castlevania their
story was really compelling you're like
you want to wipe out humanity why do you
have to humans why do you trust them but
there's a really logical reason he gives
as to why he trusts them so I'm glad
Dracula got more shine I just wish
Trevor Sipho and Alucard got a little
more shine really their entire Questers
they go to a library and do a thing
because Dracula's castle Castlevania he
can teleport it to different areas so no
one really knows where it's gonna be so
they have to find out where it's gonna
be if they can hope to bait him she's
pretty much the plot of crawl they're a
couple of throat I'm sure one throw down
in the second to the last episode it's
great and if you're a Castlevania fan
it's even better early it's a balancing
act if you give this character more
screen time the other characters have
less screen time that's just the way it
is anyone who's ever dealt with any RPG
game whatsoever you allocate points here
you have less points to allocate there
it's fact I suppose I'm saying that here
to just inform you that when you're
going into this season know that you're
gonna see more Dracula less Beaumont
doesn't change the fact that in terms of
love care and execution this Castlevania
series on Netflix is the best video game
adaptation we actually have this is
remarkably enjoyable it's not afraid to
have violence grit humor but also
recognizes that it's not just adapting
Easter eggs to the screen for you to
gush over as a fan it's actually telling
your story with characters they're a
couple of moments with Dracula it's
really sad like our castlevania symphony
of the night had those moments but the
voice acting was horrendous but the
concept was good
this actually completes that concept the
season does do that thing I've seen a
couple shows do this where the
second-to-the-last episodes actually the
season finale and then it's like the
actual season finale exists to set up
for the next season it feels like a
roller coaster that's insanely enjoyable
has loops has twists and it's like
alright it's calm for longer than it
probably should be I was kind of thrown
off at the fact that season 1 was like
oh this is Castlevania 3 but it doesn't
stay at Castlevania 3 starts moving to
other realms of Castlevania as
Castlevania lord has done and does do
but yeah you do some google searching
because I mean I love the Castlevania
games but I'm not down on all the lore
from all the games where they're going
is legit Castlevania lore and I really
like that that makes me look forward to
it more if they overplay their hand in a
certain element you're gonna be annoyed
but if they are going where I think
they're going gonna be pretty spoiled in
the end Castlevania on Netflix is great
actually just watching season 1 and
season 2 back-to-back G's have all 12
episodes to enjoy it's 12 episodes of a
show that's adapted from a video game
that really shows they care about
Castlevania lore and they're not locked
into a box they don't treat it like
alright here's some Castlevania Easter
eggs and here's a plot with
characters no they really care
they take the Castlevania lore and they
adapt it in a way that makes it
believable for what they're talking
about I mean we're talking about
vampires vampire hunters and magic
really or science but if you haven't
checked it out I highly recommend it if
you didn't check out season long as you
like it's four episodes well now there
are 12 including season 2 which is 8 all
right so Castlevania season 2 got season
2 right that's cool I'm like daredevil
season 3 that occult season 2 at this
part in that review it's a thing anyhow
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]